[Musik]
verzweiflung und protest die migranten
auf lesbos demonstrieren gegen
chaotische zustände
die polizei setzt tränengas ein bauern
unter druck nach dem ausbruch der
schweinepest in brandenburg verbietet
china die einfuhr von deutschem
schweinefleisch und zverev greift nach
dem titel zum ersten mal seit 26 jahren
steht ein deutscher tennisprofi im
einzel finale der us open
die nachrichten nicht da das sollte mit
christian sievers in allen und danke
dass sie bei uns sind gehen sie uns 20
minuten wir geben ihnen den überblick
über diesen nachrichten samstag und den
sportlichen teil hat kristin otto im
blick ist viel los heutigen abend die
lage auf lesbos ist weiter angespannt
und unübersichtlich es gibt
demonstrationen von migranten und
zusammenstöße mit der polizei
die ersten migranten können in ein neues
provisorisches zeltlager zehntausende
weitere wissen nach wie vor nicht wohin
das alte flüchtlingslager auf der
griechischen insel ist völlig zerstört
die meisten menschen aus moriya mussten
die vierte nacht in folge auf der straße
verbringen buchstäblich und zur
verzweiflung kommt wut mehr von annette
hilsenbeck tränengas gegen
protestierende migranten
die hatten zuvor steine auf die polizei
geworfen die stimmung auf lesbos
zunehmend explosiv hunderte die seit der
zerstörung marias auf der straße
ausharren müssen machen auch heute auf
ihre verzweifelte lage aufmerksam ihre
schilder an europa gewandt an
deutschland sie wollen weg wehren sich
dagegen auf der insel zu bleiben
wir mögen moria nicht filmen
griechenland nicht die leute waren zwei
tage hungrig die griechische armee baut
auf einem militärgelände nördlich des
hafen ortes mit die linie weiter an
einem vorläufigen zeltlager in einige
behausungen sind heute die ersten
familien eingezogen
bulldozer planieren weiteres gelände in
ein paar tagen sollen alle obdachlos
gewordenen hier unterkommen einen
transfer von der insel wird es nicht
geben betont griechenlands
migrationsminister wenn einige leute
denken wenn sie feuer legen und aufruhr
organisieren kriegen sie asyl können in
ein anderes europäisches land das würde
andere die hier herkommen ermuntern das
nachzuahmen
die migranten sollen wenn sie ins neue
lager kommen zunächst einen corona
schnelltest machen die sorge dass sich
das virus ausbreiten könnte ist auch
unter den flüchtlingen groß von den 35
positiv getesteten bewohnern von moria
sind die meisten seit dem brand
verschwunden
viele leute hier sind krank vielleicht
haben manche von ihnen das corona virus
es ist einfach eine katastrophe
die menschen sind dem ausgeliefert und
müssen eine weitere nacht auf der straße
verbringen und wir gehen live nachlass
borst so andreas postel guten amt
andreas wird das funktionieren so wie
sich die griechischen behörden die
nächsten tage und wochen jetzt offenbar
vorstellen
für die menschen die hinter mir heute
den zugang zum neuen zeltlager bekommen
haben wird es die erste nacht seien die
sie zumindest sein zelt dach über dem
kopf haben werden ob das für alle
funktionieren wird die soldaten hier der
griechischen armee haben heute den
ganzen tag über zelte aufgebaut und
griechenlands migrationsminister hat uns
journalisten hier versichert es werden
alle asylsuchenden hier eine unterkunft
finden und versorgung bekommen also
insofern sagen die griechen sie werden
das hier hinbekommen es ist sicherlich
auch ganz notwendig denn die vierte
nacht in folge wird es schwierig sein
für die menschen hier eine weitere nacht
unter freiem himmel zu verbringen die
verzweiflung steigt und die wut auch so
rechnet die polizei damit dass es
weitere auseinandersetzungen gibt es
gibt überall auf der insel verstärkte
polizeikräfte also das wird ziemlich
schwierig und griechenlands
migrationsminister hat ja einfach noch
eine weitere perspektive aufgezeigt
griechenland hat sehr stark auf den
europäischen migrationspfad auf einen
neuen damit diese endlich zur entlastung
kommt an europas außengrenzen hier auf
lesbos
vielen dank andreas für die menschen in
afghanistan könnte sich das heute mal
als historischer tag erweisen nach
vielen jahrzehnten mit krieg und gewalt
gibt es jetzt direkte friedensgespräche
zwischen der regierung und den radikal
islamischen taliban die beiden
delegationen treffen sich in katar mit
am tisch auch us-außenminister mike
kompon der darauf drängt einen
friedensvertrag zu schließen
doch die verhandlungen dürften extrem
schwierig werden auch in den letzten
tagen gegen die gewalt in afghanistan
weiter anfang letzter woche entging
afghanistans vizepräsident nur knapp
einem attentat zehn menschen wurden
dabei getötet
vorgestern gab es in deutschland den
ersten fall von afrikanische
schweinepest und heute wird eine
befürchtung der fleischindustrie war
china verbietet die einfuhr von
deutschem schweinefleisch das ist
gravierend denn kein land außerhalb der
eu importiert mehr deutsches
schweinefleisch als china die preise
sind hierzulande um 20 cent pro kilo
gefallen
nachgewiesen wurde wie solche in
brandenburg in schenkendöbern die
sperrzone dort ist jetzt durch einen
zaun geschützt anti klingbeil letzte
vorbereitungen in groß drewitz einem
ortsteil von schenkendöbern ein 25
kilometer langer elektrozaun soll nun
die innere schutzzone um den fundort des
infizierten wildschwein kadavers sichern
der regierungschef ist vor ort und auch
drei seiner minister
sie machen sich ein bild es steht viel
auf dem spiel sie für ganz deutschland
bedeutet das dass wir nicht mehr frei
sind von afrikanischen schweinepest und
das ist ein signal das wird natürlich
weltweit aufgenommen
der schaden ist jetzt schon groß nach
südkorea hat nun auch der größte
abnehmer china ein importverbot für
schweinefleisch verhängt 380.000 tonnen
wurden allein in der ersten jahreshälfte
dorthin geliefert
auch christoph schulz der seine schweine
in der nähe der brandenburgischen
sperrzone hält ist besorgt der
schweinepreis ist gestern schon
zusammengebrochen ja förderpreis
zusammengebrochen das hat wieder
produktionstechnische hintergründe
durch das system der massentierhaltung
entsteht jetzt schnell stau im stall
weniger tiere werden abgenommen weil die
nachfrage geringer ist viele der 23.000
schweinemastbetriebe in deutschland sind
betroffen
wir exportieren ungefähr 20 prozent in
die eu aus der eu heraus und davon gehen
60 prozent nach china
sprich ein wichtiger außer europäische
markt ist jetzt weggefallen
die ganze branche solange die
afrikanische schweinepest nur auf drei
landkreise in brandenburg begrenzt ist
bleibt zumindest der export von
schweinefleisch in die europäische union
gesichert
so und jetzt in der sendung das thema
corona da hat es in mehreren deutschen
städten wieder proteste gegeben gegen
die anti corona maßnahmen von bund und
ländern die größte veranstaltung gab es
am nachmittag auf der münchner
theresienwiese
unter der voraussetzung dass maske
getragen und abstand gehalten wird war
die großdemo doch noch genehmigt worden
daniela gabler und alexander pohl haben
den tag für uns beobachtet die stadt
münchen wollte die teilnehmerzahl
eigentlich auf 1000 beschränken
der bayerische verwaltungsgerichtshof
hob diese anordnung jedoch auf so kamen
bis zu 10.000 menschen auf der münchner
theresienwiese zusammen
immer wieder wurde die kundgebung von
der polizei unterbrochen weil teilnehmer
die hygiene auflagen nicht einhielten
[Musik]
wir gehen natürlich schritt für schritt
vor das heißt momentan ist die
versammlung unterbrochen worden
jetzt musste was haben uns leider dafür
sorgen dass sowohl abstände als auch
masken tragepflicht eingehalten werden
wo dies nicht passierte wurden
platzverweise ausgesprochen
insgesamt eine versammlung
verschiedenster gruppen von
verschwörungstheoretikern bis zu
besorgten bürgern der organisator hat
vor allem ein ziel die aufhebung der
einschränkungen durch die korona
verordnung und letztendlich auch die art
banken der bundesregierung die in dieser
pandemie komplett überreagiert hat
die menschen immer weiter in angst und
schrecken versetzt dass man schüler
zwingend einen ganzen schultag mit mass
geht darum zu sitzen das man alten
menschen älteren menschen ein redet sie
wären gefährdet sehen sind sie etwas
gefehlt aber wir sind viel mehr
gefährdet von sozialer vereinsamung wenn
ich das nicht nachvollziehen
so wie manche ebenso einschränkungen
sagen was sie sagen ist es sinnlos ein
rockkonzert mehr ein demonstrationszug
durch die stadt wurde zuvor von den
veranstaltern selbst aufgelöst nachdem
die polizei auch hier auf die einhaltung
der hygiene maßnahmen gedrängt hatte
insgesamt aber sprechen die beamten
bislang von einem friedlichen verlauf
der demonstration die zahl der
gemeldeten neuen corona infektionen in
deutschland bleibt relativ stabil im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1350 menschen mit dem
virus angesteckt gestern waren es 1330
aufnäher verzichten den zeiten von
corona dass es ganz besonders schwer für
diejenigen die am ende ihres lebens
stehen die wissen dass ihr leben bald zu
ende geht und natürlich gerade dann
nicht allein gelassen werden möchten
für die palliativmediziner ist dass die
große herausforderung sterbenden auch
jetzt einen angemessenen abschied vom
leben möglich zu machen
isabel de la vega hat mit ärzten
schwerstkranken und ihren familien
gesprochen
seinen vater erinnert sven fiedler als
vitalen und geselligen man den
lungenkrebs ertrug er tapfer doch die
soziale isolation durch corona ließ den
66-jährigen verzweifeln
aus angst ihn womöglich anzustecken
sahen die freunde von besuchen ab doch
irgendwann gesagt als es noch ging ich
würde gern mit dem noch wenig würde gern
noch mal sehen
aber das bleibt mir wohl verwehrt das
wurde ihm auch für wert also schon
harten einsam
die palliativstation des st josefs
hospitals in wiesbaden wegen corona
dürfen wir nur draußen drehen die
besuchsmöglichkeiten wurden massiv
eingeschränkt besonders die
sterbenskranken aber sind auf die nähe
von freunden und verwandten angewiesen
eine der großen ängste und der großen
verluste die das am lebensende stehen
mit sich bringt ist dass einbußen
einbüßten von sozialen kontakten von
emotionaler präsenz von ja das gefühl
verloren zu sein oder verloren zu gehen
gertrud marx hat lungenkrebs und möchte
keine lebensverlängernden maßnahmen
sie wird deshalb auf der
palliativstation betreut was ihr jetzt
wichtig ist und hilft dass die familie
so zusammenhält
mittlerweile konnte sie das krankenhaus
wieder verlassen und wird zu hause von
einem palliativ team betreut nicht
allein zu sterben ist gertrud marx
letzter großer wunsch
in indien breitet sich das virus nach
wie vor unkontrolliert aus das land
meldet nach den usa die meisten fälle
weltweit und nirgendwo stecken sich
täglich so viele menschen an wie dort
schauen uns das mal genauer an die
gemeldeten neuinfektionen klettern
weiter und weiter nach oben gestern
waren es 97 1570 an nur einem tag
in indien ist der kampf gegen das virus
einer jenseits der belastungsgrenze
berichtet normen odenthal
sie arbeiten am anschlag seit tagen
wochen monaten tun ihr bestes und müssen
doch mit ansehen wie die lage in indien
immer schlimmer wird fast 100.000
neuinfizierte an jedem einzelnen tag
wenn ärzte nicht mehr weiter wissen was
dann
wir sind körperlich und mental am ende
du hast hier keine pause bis immer
angespannt es kommen immer mehr
patienten und sie sind immer kränker für
uns wird es noch härter
der strenge lockdown wird weiter
gelockert so kehrt das leben zurück und
nimmt das sterben zu die zahlen
dramatisch offiziell viereinhalb
millionen infizierte vermutlich liegt
die dunkelziffer viel höher
es ist nur eine frage der zeit bis wir
die usa als am schlimmsten betroffen das
land überholen
wir brauchen einen neuen lockdown sonst
wird es fürchten
es darf keinen neuen lockdown geben
sonst wird alles nur noch schlimmer wenn
du raus gehst kannst du vielleicht an
der krankheit sterben aber wenn sie uns
einsperren dann verhungern wir so viel
ist klar wirtschaft und virus vertragen
sich nicht die konjunktur kollabiert wir
müssen öffnen sagt die regierung und
gibt ein signal mit risiken und
nebenwirkungen
die leute verstehen licht sie glauben
die beschränkungen werden gelockert also
ist die pandemie vorbei und keiner hält
mehr abstand
so kann corona weiter wüten 1,4
milliarden menschen leben in indien oft
beengt viele arm mit dürftiger
medizinischer versorgung ein enormes
potenzial für das aggressive virus und
so viel in dieser sendung zum thema
corona es sind wieder vor allem die
frauen die auch heute in der
belarussischen hauptstadt minsk auf die
straße gehen der protest gegen
staatschef alexander lukaschenko lässt
nicht nach und die sondereinheiten der
polizei gehen jetzt brutal auch gegen
die frauen vor alleine der ersten stunde
der proteste wurden mindestens 30
menschen in polizeifahrzeuge gesteckt
christiansen mit mehr mit vereinten
kräften gegen die vermummte staatsgewalt
mutige frauen stemmen sich gegen die
spezialkräfte die wieder einmal brutal
versuchen die proteste zu beenden
die frauen wollen wissen mit wem sie es
hier zu tun haben versuchen den männern
die sturmhaube vom kopf zu reißen und
verhindern
zumindest in dieser szene weitere
festnahmen die die eigene gedanken haben
eine eigene stimme versucht man zum
schweigen zu bringen mit hilfe solcher
grausamen mittel
es ist mir egal wenn lukaschenko einfach
nur zurücktritt und nie wieder am
belarussischen horizont auftaucht am
mittag waren es wieder tausende die dem
aufruf der opposition gefolgt waren und
wie hier in minsk auf die straße gingen
trotz drohungen und festnahmen des lukas
schenkel systems das weiter keine
antworten auf die proteste hat außer mit
brutaler härte vorzugehen
bis zum abend gab es mehr als 30
festnahmen
die gewalt des staates macht viele hier
weiter fassungslos und wütend
ganz vorne dabei auch wieder nina
baginsky die 73-jährige geologen ist zu
einem gesicht der proteste geworden
immer wieder stellt sie sich mutig in
den weg
die leute gehen weiter tapfer auf die
straße und haben keine angst vor diesen
repressionen wovor soll ich angst haben
in meinem alter wäre es lächerlich angst
zu haben
nina baginsky will noch lange nicht
aufgeben und die proteste werden
weitergehen morgen schon
zurück nach deutschland zu einer
demonstration heute in leipzig linke
gruppen protestieren gegen die
europäische flüchtlingspolitik und die
chinesische regierung ihr motto die
festung europa stürmen
das war eigentlich geplant als
gegenprogramm zum eu china gipfel der
aber wegen corona ausfällt beobachter
schätzten die teilnehmerzahl auf etwa
300 menschen angekündigt waren 800
nachdem es bei demos am vergangenen
wochenende ausschreitungen gab ist die
polizei mit einem großaufgebot vor ort
entlang der westküste der usa brennt es
weiter lichterloh mindestens 26 menschen
sind schon gestorben
viele weitere werden vermisst die
behörden befürchten dass die zahl der
todesopfer weiter steigt
in oregon sind manche kleinstädte fast
komplett abgebrannt zehntausende
menschen mussten ihre wohnungen
verlassen und die brände kommen auch der
großstadt portland immer näher
die feuer wüten in mehreren
bundesstaaten am heftigsten den
kalifornien und oregon mehr als 20.000
quadratkilometer sind verbrannt das
entspricht etwa der fläche von rheinland
pfalz kaum vorstellbar und die lage ist
noch lange nicht unter kontrolle und die
haupt waldbrandsaison kommt erst noch so
viel von den nachrichten in dieser
sendung dann hätten wir jetzt den sport
und ich habe gleich mal was schönes es
ist 31 jahre her dass boris becker als
letzter deutscher tennisprofi die us
open im einzel gewonnen hat morgen abend
hat nun alexander zverev diese große
chance äußerst nerven stark nach einem 0
2 rückstand sicherte er sich erstmalig
new york den finaleinzug knapp drei
stunden und 23 minuten ist es geschafft
da können wir herrscht könnte nicht
glücklicher sein aber mir fehlt noch ein
letzter schritt in den ersten beiden
sätzen ist der 23-jährige deutsche gegen
pablo carreño buste aus spanien
unerwartet passiv und fehlerhaft
verliert diese mit 3 6 und 2 6 mit dem
rücken zur wand kämpft er sich zurück
gewinnt den dritten und vierten satz
der gegner dann sichtlich geschwächt
nach einer behandlungspause nutzt zverev
das momentum und sichert sich den
entscheidenden fünften satz mit 6 zu 3
im finale am sonntag trifft der
hamburger nun auf seinen
österreichischen freund dominic thiem
der bereits zum vierten mal ein grand
slam endspiel bestreitet laura siegemund
aus metzingen hat sich bereits den traum
vom us- open- gewinn erfüllt im doppel
finale der frauen gemeinsam mit der
russin vera swonarewa besiegte sie das
duo nica joe aus den usa und china mit
zweimal 6 zu 4
nun reisen die beiden nach paris mit dem
ziel auch bei den french open zu
triumphieren
im streit um die rückkehr von fans in
die stadien und sporthallen drängen die
bundesländer auf eine einheitliche
lösung die das zdf aus der
arbeitsgemeinschaft der chefs der
staatskanzleien erfahren hat soll es
schnellstmöglich eine bundesweite
richtlinie geben die eine zulassung von
30 bis 40 prozent des fassungsvermögens
der jeweiligen sportstätte ermöglicht
dies gelte dann für alle
sportveranstaltungen und mehr dazu sowie
zum auftakt des dfb pokals von 23 uhr an
bei dunja hayali im aktuellen
sportstudio
nach dem aus von hertha bsc gestern
abend haben sich heute bisher alle sechs
erstligisten durchgesetzt und noch zur
tour de france der tross rollt richtung
alpen 1494 kilometer nach lyon mit einem
leicht welligen profil und einem
dänischen tagessieger im alleingang
synchro anders
lennart kemna gestern noch knapp dran
damit haben sich heute überall zu finden
als tempobolzer für den slowaken peter
sagan viele seiner sprint konkurrenten
fallen dadurch vorzeitig zurück kemna
ist auch wasserträger für seine kollegen
und trotzdem setzte er auf dem hügeligen
kurs indio einer attacke
es ist aber nicht die entscheidende die
kommt von synchro andersen drei
kilometer vor dem ziel etappenerfolg für
den 26 jahre alten damon und seine in
deutschland lizensierte steam sunweb
sagan im sprint der verfolger zwar nicht
der schnellste er holt durch platz vier
jedoch wertvolle punkte im kampf um das
grüne trikot und formel 1 weltmeister
lewis hamilton startet morgen erneut
kann der poleposition dies meine mugello
sebastian vettel kann finden sagte
kristin also noch lust auf berlin
in ganz neuem licht das festival of
lights strahlt eine woche lang nicht das
erste mal aber dieses mal überall in der
ganzen stadt eine lebendige galerie mit
riesen kunstwerken das motto together we
schein zusammen leuchten wir poppige
farben auf historischen fassaden laut
veranstalter ein zeichen für reinheit
und zusammenhalt spätsommerliche
aussichten beim wetter kein regen in
sicht sonne und wärme begleiten uns weit
in die nächste woche wie schön
mehr gleich von katja oliver ich
empfehle ihnen das heute schon mit den
kollegen claus kleber um 22.45 wir sagen
danke für ihr interesse bis morgen aber
erst in allen einen sehr angenehmen
samstagabend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren der
himmel erscheint uns derzeit häufig
milchig trüb das sehen sie hier auf
unsere satellitenbild das hängt zusammen
mit den rauch partikeln mit den
aerosolen der brände in kalifornien
denn diese rauchpartikel werden weit
nach osten getrieben noch besser sehen
sie die rauchpartikel natürlich über
kalifornien aber auch in den nächsten
tagen werden rauchpartikel bei uns
ankommen das liegt an der kombination
der tiefs renate und saskia und den
hochs kevin und nike kevin und lucky
werden eine hochdruckbrücke ausbilden
das bedeutet für uns spätsommerwetter
sonnenschein wärme und kein regen heute
nach geht es allenfalls etwas nebel in
norddeutschland sind die wolken etwas
dichter bei südwestwind und die
temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 7 grad
morgen steigen sie der meist auf
sommerliche 25 bis 30 grad und nur im
norddeutschen flachland bleibt ist bei
21 bis 24 etwas kühler
das liegt dann dort auch an den etwas
dichteren wolkenfeldern in
süddeutschland scheint die sonne zum
teil strahlend und das tut sie auch noch
in den nächsten tagen ob dann allerdings
tatsächlich 34 grad erreicht werden
hängt auch davon ab ob die rauchpartikel
das sonnenlicht dollar schwächen
wir warten was ab schönes wochenende